and nina maybe we can get started now
yeah
all right so
welcome back so our next speaker is
elena from university of
wisconsin-madison and
she has been doing a lot of fantastic
work on variation inequalities and
equilibrium so without further ado yes
that is yours
thank you very much neo and
thank you and the other organizers for
organizing this great workshop it's a
pleasure to give this talk
so i thought i would talk today about
work that i
did
now more than two years ago
but it is still quite relevant and
so i'll spend some time explaining that
at work and then i'll talk about some
more recent developments including some
work of mine that's not even
posted yet
okay so
i'll start with the
basic motivation which comes from min
max optimization and i will not be
spending too much time here because i
feel like you have seen this over and
over again so
uh no need to dwell too much on it but
the
basic motivation for
what i'll be talking about is min max or
saddle point optimization
where we want to minimize the function
over x and maximize over why
uh i will always be assuming that if we
have a constrained setup that
these
feasible sets x and y are closed and
convex
and for most of the talk i will be
assuming that this function f is convex
concave and then towards the end of the
talk i will mention some extension to
cases when the function is potentially
not
convex concave
one of the most basic facts as we all
know is that when we have a function
that is convex concave and the feasible
sets that are compact
then uh min max point is guaranteed to
exist and the
min and max are exchangeable
there are of course some generalizations
to
this seminal result of one neumann but
in general once we
relax
the
condition that the function is convex
concave we cannot
go
much further in in guaranteeing a result
like this uh the problem becomes in fact
very difficult as you have seen also in
other talks that uh mentioned some of
the hardness results uh there is a whole
research area that looks at
when local
solutions even exist and and
there are different ways of even
defining what local solutions are as we
saw initiate stock
but we do care about these setups where
the function is potentially non-convex
non-concave
when it comes to the types of guarantees
that we typically look at
when we have some candidates approximate
solution
there are two
most basic guarantees the first one is
guaranteeing that we have a small
optimality gap or maybe more precisely
more precise thing to say here would be
a primal dual gap so what we want to
ensure that when we move away from our
candidate solution in either y direction
or x direction we cannot improve by more
than epsilon this type of guarantee is
mainly meaningful for convex concave
functions
there is also another guarantee that
we can talk about and it is a
stationarity guarantee it is meaningful
in
any setups where f is also potentially
non-conductive non-concave i will mainly
talk about setups where f is
differentiable so so i can write things
like gradient
this is just a
generalization of stationarity would
have in standard min optimization and if
the setup is unconstrained it just
reduces to requiring that we have a
small gradient
now i
gave i'm giving here minimax
optimization is the main motivation but
there are
much more general problems that can be
studied and and the work i'll talk about
actually covers also those
generalizations
so in in terms of the
basic problems that we tend to look at
as abstractions of min max but also
generalizations of min max
we
often work with
operators that are monotone
and the monotone means that we can
satisfy an inequality uh that looks like
this
now gradients of convex functions are
monotone but also for conducts concave
functions if we take the if we stack the
gradients and we put a minus here with
respect to the concave part we also get
a monotone operator
if a function was not convex concave
then we wouldn't have a monotone
operator
there are some basic variational
inequalities problems that are usually
defined for monotone operators
and
they are defined in terms of
what looks like equilibria so we want to
find the
solution point you start such that we
satisfy some type of an inequality
and
there are two types of inequalities they
correspond to weak and strong solutions
uh the difference here is where you
evaluate this operator f if this doesn't
make sense don't worry about it i i will
give you kind of the bottom line of the
story very soon there is a third type of
a problem and then that's the one i have
been focusing on which is known as
monotone inclusion
where we want to find a zero
of
this operator f uh now
this is just finding a zero of f is
sufficient for unconstrained setups
there is another part we add here when
we also want to cover constrained setups
so this would just be
the sub-differential of the indicator
function of the convex set mainly what
it does it just
ensures that the problem is still
meaningful and gives you the right
notion of stationarity if a solution
happens to fall
at the
on the boundary of a feasible reach
in
if you want an intuitive way of thinking
about these problems and translating
them back to
min max optimization variational
inequalities will normally translate
into guarantees on optimality gap or
more broadly primal dual gap
monotone inclusion will be translating
into the problem of
finding a stationary point so in an
unconstrained setups finding the point
with a small gradient
now if you want to
compare
these three types of problems and their
corresponding solutions
there is a very basic fact that says
when we have a monotone operator
then the solution sets of all these
three problems are the same so so there
is no difference in whether you're
solving monotone inclusion or either one
of these two variational inequality
problems
so
you know you might be already wondering
so why am i focusing on monotone
inclusion
well
the thing is we never really solve these
problems to optimality what we can only
hope for is that we solve them
approximately so when we are solving
these problems we would be solving them
to some accuracy epsilon
now you can uh define
the appropriate epsilon approximations
to these problems for monotone inclusion
you just add some epsilon margin this is
a ball of radius epsilon and it means
exactly that so if you were looking for
a small gradient it would mean that you
find the gradient with norm at most
epsilon and you can define the same
thing for variational inequalities where
you replace this zero that was
on the right hand side by some epsilon
now the things become much more
interesting when you look at approximate
solutions
uh because
already
uh when you start looking at the
unconstrained setup
approximations to weaken strong
va solutions become meaningless and what
i mean by that is that unless you have
an optimal solution
the
guarantee that you get would be that you
have an infinite error and let's quickly
look at uh just a very simple example so
consider having the bilinear problem
and just x times y
the
monotone operator you get from there
would be y and minus x just according to
the definition we wrote
before and
this problem actually has a solution and
it is unique at 0 0.
now if you try moving away from 0 0 to
any other point
and you look at the guarantees you you
can have
well this here would be your strong
solution guarantee you need to take
supremum because uh this inequality
needs to hold for every you from a
feasible set and now feasible set is all
of r2
by monotonicity of this operator
uh this is greater than or equal to the
weak solution guarantee
now you plug in the definition of f
in here
and you get something that looks like
this
now it should be immediate to you
because i'm taking supremum over x and y
if i have x bar and y bar
where either of them is non-zero i can
push this to premium to infinity
so what this means i'm giving you an
example that if you're in the
unconstrained domain and you want to
have
the direct definition of what
approximation is for variational
inequalities and in this case also for
the
optimality cap
then this just it does not make any
sense
now there is uh
more to say even in cases uh when you
have uh constrained setups that are
bounded so the diameter of the set is
bounded
and what you can say in general is that
the set of all of epsilon approximate vi
solutions
contains all of the epsilon approximate
strong vi solutions which in turn
contains all the epsilon over d
approximate solutions to monotone
inclusion
what this means is that if i solve
monotone inclusion
to error epsilon over d
i get
an absolute approximate solution to
strong vi
and i also get epsilon approximate
solution to weak fi so monotone
inclusion is in fact the most general
of these problems
and this epsilon over d actually doesn't
lose anything
so if i have an algorithm with optimal
iteration complexity for monotone
inclusion it immediately implies
algorithms with optimal iteration
complexity for either
of the two vi guarantees
this this is the reason why i was
interested in monotony inclusion
now
the work i did was uh back in 2020 so so
this will mainly summarize uh
kind of history bits up to that point
before this work existed and i'll talk
about some uh developments that happened
after that uh in the later part of the
talk
so as far as i know and and could find
just by searching the
history of these problems min max
optimization was originally studied
within game theory and economics and and
at least initially people were mostly
concerned with the existence of uh
equilibria with the existence of
minmax solutions
variational inequalities even though
they are
today studied as obstructions of minimax
actually came from a different line of
work
they started with the something called
senorini problem
in 1959 which is an equilibrium problem
that comes from dynamical systems
and their systematic study
started the
in 1960s it was initiated by
guidostatumpakia after whom you know
strong the eyes are named
and he was the person who coined the
term variational inequalities
now in terms of algorithms these
connections between variational
inequalities and the
min max optimization were observed quite
early on and many of the algorithms that
were developed
would apply to both problems
in terms of the asymptotic convergence
we have results at least as early as the
1970s
in terms of non-asymptotic convergence
where we have explicit rate guarantees
first type of results that that existed
were
uh
for the setups where you can obtain
linear convergence and then so this
applied to uh at least in the setup of
min max optimization to problems that
were either bilinear or strongly
monotone
now when it comes to convergence to weak
vi solutions
and
you look at standard classes of problems
so so you don't necessarily
you don't necessarily require that you
have this strong monotonicity
so
you have things like bounded gradients
uh lipschitz gradients and and so on
uh
there was a lot of work
starting at least with the work of uh
nemirovsky and uh there has been a lot
of follow-up work uh more recently in
the animal community that gives
different interpretations of these
results and and maybe some
nicer proofs but
here in the case when we have lip sheets
monotone operators we can get
uh
complexity that is of the order one over
epsilon
if you move away from weak solutions
so if you want guarantees for strong
solutions or monotone inclusion
there was much less work at least when
it comes to having a rate guarantees
uh prior to my work the main two results
i am aware of were the results of uh dan
ganlan and rue adele the balance they
got were suboptimal and then i'll show
them in a table uh in a bit
okay so so the results i will be talking
about here are uh from this paper that
appeared
back in
2020 i apologize for the noise
there is a train going next to my office
and that's what's causing uh
distance hopefully you can still hear me
so to
stating results a bit easier
i will just focus on the basic version
of the results but
you can state them in full generality
for
uh
monthly inclusion i i just want to
give you kind of a
an easy picture to
keep in mind
so the most basic goal
is
that we have a convex concave function
so
this f operator that i'll remind you
what it is here in the corner is
monotone
and we
are given an error parameter epsilon and
we want to find the point that has the
norm of this operator that is at most
epsilon
now this problem
as i said is well defined even when
approximating the gap is not
and in general what can be said is that
if i get an optimal rate
for
making this operator norm small it
implies the optimal rate for the
optimality gap
now you may be wondering whether the
opposite
holds as well
and as you may suspect it does not
and it is not only
you know artificial that it does not
hold in general but if we look at
standard algorithms that we would use
for the optimality gap
for those algorithms we would probably
get sub-optimal rate
so what they can tell you informally is
that
if you have a lipschitz monotone
operator
the optimal rate for reducing
this norm of the operator is one over k
if you look at the
algorithms that achieve that
optimal rate for reducing optimality
gaps so things that you're all familiar
with like extra gradient mirror procs
pop-ups method dual extrapolation
all of these methods and methods similar
to them
have sub-optimal rate for reducing this
norm of the operator and it is not
faster than one over root k and this
follows uh from the results of golovich
patatel the skelakis nostagler from call
2020.
now to state the results i need to tell
you what are the problem classes i look
at and the problem classes i had looked
at are all the
standard problem classes where you would
have limp sheets monotone operators
so the first problem class corresponds
to operators that are co-coercive
this is a very very strong assumption
it implies that uh the operator is both
lip sheets and monotone the opposite
direction does not hold
but it is the most basic case to
understand and as i'll show you when you
understand this basic case it is
possible to build on it and obtain
results for other problem classes
the other problem class is when f would
be monotone and ellipses and you know
it's your standard definition of
lipschitzness
the third problem class would be when f
is in addition to being ellipse it's
also m coercive or m strongly monotone
meaning that there is this quadratic
lower bound
on
this inner product
so so just to to quickly compare
these two things so so this would
correspond to things like a strong
function being strongly convex strongly
concave
if you had a zero here it would just
mean that the
operator is monotone
when you have this quadratic distance it
is strongly monotone and this this is
the strongest assumption that you can
make here
co coercive is different because here
you have f of u minus f of v instead of
human minus v
i should mention that
the results i'll present
in fact apply to
a relaxed version of strong monotonicity
called
sharpness where
an inequality like this would apply
uh when you restrict one of the points
to be
a solution to the problem
so so there are problems that are
sharp but they're not strongly monotonic
it's a wider class but to
be able to compare to other results and
and not complicate things too much i
will mainly be mentioning strongly one
of them but i just wanted to uh mention
this to you in case you were wondering
now my focus in this first work was
mainly on methods that are parameter
free meaning that they can work without
knowing what these parameters l and m
are so the method can know what problem
class the problem comes from but not to
know either of these parameters
here is a big table that summarizes the
results and
it's a bit too much so so i'll tell you
how to read it so so there are three
main columns
and these three main columns correspond
to the three classes of problems so
co-coercive lab sheets and monotone
legit and strongly monotone
and then there are three sub columns for
the three types of solution weak vi
strong vi monotone inclusion
the first row are the results from my
work
the
second row are the best known results at
the time this work was done
and the green color here indicates that
the results are parameter free you do
not need to know parameters whereas red
here means that you do need to know the
parameters for those algorithms
and so for the co-coercive class we
already had a good
sense of
complexity
and
there were
methods out there that were getting the
optimal
iteration or oracle complexity
but
we didn't have parameter free algorithms
for stronger guarantees
for ellipsis and monotony it is not only
about uh the complexity result so so
here this o tilde just hides log one
over epsilon factors it is slightly
worse for for weak vi but for the other
two cases at the time this work was done
there was a quadratic improvement here
in terms of dependence on epsilon
the
diameter of the set and initial distance
to the optimum
for
the lipsticks and strongly monotone
results
um
the parameter free part is a little bit
implicit in uh
one of the papers here but i have
checked and it works it is possible to
make those uh
algorithms parameter free the result i
get here is off by a factor uh log
condition number so log l over m
but it applies also beyond strong
monotonicity as i said to this sharpness
so let me now tell you a little bit
about uh how these results were obtained
and all of the results i'll talk about
are
one way or another related to something
called halpern iteration
so what is halpern iteration it it's a
very very old algorithm
uh it was developed in 1967
and
traditionally it was used for solving
fixed point equations of non-expansive
maps
so non-expensive map means that you have
a map that is one lipsticks it doesn't
expand distances but it is not
necessarily contractive
uh fixed points you know i hope you know
what fixed point means
so there were uh results
that were establishing non-asymptotic
grades for halpern uh
most of them were not that great but
then uh
sometimes 2017 there were two uh papers
that got
uh this rate which is of the order one
over k
uh i'll mention maybe this briefly but
this also turns out to be the optimal
rate you can get
so you know this is for non-expensive
maps
what's the point i'm not looking at
unexpected non-expensive maps
well non-extensive maps are
very closely related to co-coercive
operators
in fact that there is just a linear
transformation that would take me from
one to the other
so if i have
an
operator that is one over l co coercive
i can just take identity minus two over
l times f and i'm going to get an
operator that is not expensive
so in principle i could be applying
halperin iteration to
this non-expensive operator
now the question is why
and does this give me anything
well if you
actually take
this transformation and you look at what
is the fixed point now of this
non-expensive map that i defined
well you know you write the
fixed point and then this essentially
means just that the
uh you're finding the zero
of this operator and that's what we want
so this precisely gives me what i want
and
in terms of these existing results if
you just do the translation they would
already give you one over k convergence
rate for making this operator norm small
but
you would need to know
this parameter l to be able to apply it
so what i was wondering about when i
started working
on this problem was can we do this
without knowing girl and also the
analysis that was
presented in a leader's paper wasn't
quite clear what was going on there so i
wanted to
develop a different convergence argument
that i could build on
so from now on uh the algorithm that we
will work with
is uh just uh this equivalent variant of
hull permutation but now applied to
co-coercive operators
and the
yeah maybe let me just quickly note so
so what is uh interesting about this
algorithm that it does something called
anchoring uh it always mixes in
a small amount of the initial point
and then this other thing you can
think of as a gradient step
it seems like a minor point super
important for convergence if you
remove this
you probably would not get
the optimal rate so it is quite this
anchoring is super crucial uh this step
lime decay is usually of the order one
over k
okay
so the analysis of the algorithm that i
came up with back in this work was based
on the potential function
and
this potential function and the
algorithm will use some guests for the
co-coercivity parameter
and as i said this slum the k is just
the step size
there is intuition behind this uh
potential function
in that
it
does
a kind of a trade-off between
the norm of the operator
and some notion of a gap with respect to
the anchor point
i won't get to talk about it
here
i have other works that
actually showed that for other
algorithms in other setups that are
that give optimal guarantees in terms of
the gradient
you can usually come up with potential
functions that look like this
so there is kind of a broader phenomenon
of what is going on here
now
why is this potential function useful
well
the analysis hinges on the following
argument so you want to argue that this
potential function is non-positive for
all k
and then if you have something like this
you know you just rearrange this thing
being less than or equal to zero
and it gives you a bound
on the operator norm squared and now the
question is you know how to use this
well it's actually quite simple you add
and subtract
some solution u star
because it is a solution
you can argue that this part will be
non-positive
and
you apply question schwartz to the first
term
and you get something like this
if the operator norm was zero you you
would have already been done so assume
it is not you cancel it
on
both sides
sorry
my slides are not updating well so you
cancel it on both sides and you get
something like this so so it gives you a
bound on the
operator norm at the iteration k in
terms of the initial distance
now all that remains is to ensure that
this works for
your estimate being correct it's not
being too much off by more than a
constant
and that can be guaranteed
and that the analysis works for
step sizes of the order one over k and
and uh that's what is done in this paper
and you get the correct iteration
complexity
now this is the most uh
basic setup and it is possible to extend
this result to other problem classes
because i won't have enough time i will
not be telling you
i will not be giving you all the details
on how to do that but let me just hash
out the
main ideas
for what you would do
so
what they
talked about was for unconstrained setup
you can also generalize to constrain
setups uh using something known as
operator mapping or natural mapping it
is similar to gradient mapping and
convex optimization and it is kind of
the
um it seems like the right thing to do
when you have projections
to go to setups with monotone and lip
sheets operators
there is a way to do that by using
something called a resolvent
operator
there is a standard fact about resolvent
operators that when you have
an operator that is monotone and you
apply a resolvent to it it will you'll
get a non-expensive
operator
now
because you get a non-expensive operator
you can apply this you can apply help
penetration to it uh there is of course
some technical work missing there
because
you need uh
to get an algorithm that computationally
makes sense you need to work with
inexact resolvence so the analysis needs
to be extended to work with inexact
operator evaluations and this is what is
done what you lose in the process is
just this log one over epsilon factor so
it becomes kind of a
two loop algorithm
and the
to go to strongly monotone setups uh
what's
is shown here is that you can use
adaptive restart mainly you use this
algorithm for mono to unleash its case
and you just restart it every time you
have
the operator norm
and
all of these results
are near optimal so in this work we
actually certify that using uh lower
bound reductions uh from a result that
holds for
uh
optimality gap in min max optimization
and was obtained by we young and sue
so so this uh essentially resolves the
the whole class up to some
logarithmic factor uh what i have not
explicitly mentioned here but it should
be clear to you from this guarantee is
that all of these results are for the
last iterate
there is a particular reason i really
really like culprit iteration
well there's more than one reason but
one of them is
this
very interesting structural result
that
tells us that helper iteration is
implicitly regularized method and what i
mean by that is that if you have a
problem where your
solution is not unique
then helper and iteration is guaranteed
to converge to the closest
solution
to the one from where you started
so if you
have zero
within your feasible set
and you initialize from zero
you get the minimum norm
solution
now the results i have talked about so
far
although i didn't explicitly say this
they're all for euclidean norm
this structural result holds for any
norm
in particular holds even if you have l1
norm here
so if you could make this work for l1
norm you would be getting implicitly
sparse solutions
now what i talked about were the results
from the work back in 2020 and now i
want to tell you about some more recent
uh developments and and uh what has been
improved and
tightened
since the initial dissemination of this
work
uh
there were improvements to lower bounds
so
because the lower bounds
in my first paper were using this lower
bound reductions they were not tight
they were losing some log factors
so i had a paper about a year ago with
my student
that
showed that
for the co-corrosive setup
this type of lower bound holds so
this direct application of help and
iteration to co-currency setup is
optimal gives you
iteration complexity optimal result or
oracle complexity optimal result
co-coercive implies a lower bound also
for monotone and lipschitz
uh i should say however the lower bound
we had here it had some restriction it
wasn't
just the first order oracle uh
lower bound we were assuming you know
that the new points you construct based
on previously seen
uh
operators or gradients
there is a strengthening
of that
result to
uh
just gradient oracle setup
by young and ryu
and
it calls for monotone lipsticks
operators uh what you can conclude from
here is that the result i told you about
that uses resolve and is just optimal by
log one over epsilon factor
uh there have also been improvements in
terms of the upper bounds
so
uh the same paper by yoon and vu
actually shaves off this log one over
epsilon factor
uh instead of having this inner loop
they get an algorithm that is similar to
extra gradient but
it is not extra gradient it is a variant
of hull permutation it's just a two-step
variant of whole period iteration
and the
you know based on this lower bound this
is optimal iteration complexity
and there was another uh paper that also
appeared in 2021 that gets the same
result but uh for an optimistic or pop
of like variant of helper iteration the
difference is just
that here you would need two
operator evaluations per iteration here
you need only one and then this paper
also gives some other results
one thing that is very interesting to me
and
this is to my current understanding
there may be something i'm missing but
you can correct me if i'm wrong
so far the results of this type that
give you guarantee
for the last iterate
and give you
oracle complexity
optimal results are all based on helper
iteration
so it seems to be kind of the correct
view of the problem
this view of relating co-creativity
with
fixed points of non-expensive maps
and when i say
last iterate
i mean that you get the optimal rate for
any notion of convergence only with the
variant of health penetration and in
fact helping iteration
gives you the strongest guarantee you
can get which is the guarantee for
monotone
inclusion there have also been
extensions that go beyond monotone
setups
and uh one such extension is to
something uh
to a setup where you have a property
called
a negative co-monotonicity
oh
this is a typo here it should be f of u
minus f of v uh sorry about that
so the negative co monotone gives a
condition like this it just should be f
of u minus f of b
again
now
this negative common atomicity has been
studied since at least the
90s
it came up in works that we're trying to
understand
why some variants of proximal point
method were converging even on problems
that were not monotone
there have been
multiple characterizations of what it
means to have negative co-monotone
operators one of them is that the
resolvent operator is non-extensive this
is a resolvent operator
now
what this means is that the results uh
from my paper from 2020 already implies
that if you apply help per iteration
with resolvence you get
something close to the optimum for row
less than one so
you lose log one over epsilon here for
approximating the resolve and the reason
i did not include this back
then was that the algorithm was not
parameter free and it kind of didn't fit
nice to the whole story
there are improvements to this result
and there was a paper by lean kim
that
gets a result without
this log one over epsilon
where you just restrict this row to be
up to one over two l
whether this is necessary or not
we don't know but it is a it is a very
very nice result and quite technical to
get
uh it is based on an extra gradient like
variant of helper iteration and their
results can be made
it's very nice
beyond halpern and kind of into the
similar class of
problems
we had a
result that was addressing a broader
class than this comonotone where
you only need the property like this to
hold uh when one of the point is optimal
solution
but
the
complexity becomes worse so it goes from
one over epsilon to 1 over epsilon
squared
the
final thing i want to talk about and
then i'll wrap up i just need a few more
minutes
is
when we have stochastic setups
and
this is a very very recent work uh with
my student shuffon sai uh my postdoc
chopping song with my collaborator
christophel guzman
the paper is not online yet but we hope
to post it uh
very soon maybe the next few days
so
we
look at this problem of monotone
inclusion so the same up
same classes of problems
but now we assume that we have
stochastic oracle access
to this operator
and their standard assumptions you can
always make in stochastic approximation
settings that you have an unbiased
estimator and
bionde variants
there is an additional assumption that
we make
which is this multi-point oracle
assumption made also in some
prior work
which just assumes that you can query
multiple points with the same random
seed
we don't know how to get the results to
talk about without this assumption
seems kind of crucial if you can relax
it that would be very interesting
uh
if you look at the uh higher state of
the arts
the best results for stochastic setup
that i'm aware of are of the order one
over epsilon to the fourth
and there are a few papers that can get
this type of guarantee they
would typically use mini batching
and they do not actually need this
multi-point oracle assumption but what
this buys is that
we can
do very introduction i'll talk about
that in the next slide there are better
results than this so this seems rather
high uh there are better results for
optimality gap
you know classical ones also some more
recent ones it's unclear how to
translate them to
the gradients or this monotone inclusion
so our basic idea in the work was just
combine all these optimal variants of
hull per iteration which we know our
iteration complexity optimally
deterministic static setting combine
them with variance reduction
and there was a question what variance
reduction method to use
uh there is a specific recursive
variance reduction method that worked
well for us it's called page
uh i suspect that others would work too
but this one was just convenient for the
analysis
and that method was developed originally
for non-convex optimization where you're
just minimizing the function i as far as
i know it has never been used in this
specific setup
idea is super simple
we knew exactly what we wanted to get
getting there was quite complicated and
we end up
with a
pretty intricate inductive argument
even though we used the the same
potential function as before
so these are the results
so uh without variance reduction the
complexity was one over epsilon to the
fourth here we reduce it to one over
epsilon cubed
and then for the ellipse strongly
monotone setup we get one over epsilon
squared log one over epsilon
now you may be wondering can you do
better
uh
you can't
so so it is possible to argue that
this is optimal up to log factors
i'm displaying the dependence here only
on epsilon there is dependence on other
parameters
that dependence i think can be improved
but the dependence on epsilon
no
okay so
there are two main things that i want to
tell you here
for all these standard classes of
problems with lipschitz monotone
operators
we get
iteration complexity optimal results
with variance of helper and iteration
as far as i know
only variants of helper integration give
this type of results
so i i believe this is worth further
study
another thing that i find interesting is
that all the existing arguments
for these variants of hull per iteration
are based on the same potential function
uh which was
introduced in this work from 2020.
and there is a downside and that is that
all of these results are only for
euclidean norms
and we also care about other norms
so some open questions first
is can we generalize this to other norms
and in particular i would be very
interested in l1 norm
there are reasons why this is difficult
i don't have the time to get into that
uh
are there other
types of algorithms that can give this
results and that do not boil down to
some variant of hull permutation
i think it's interesting to understand
and uh can we address more general
non-monotone setups and still get these
same nice optimal
rates so i'll stop here and i'm happy to
take any questions you might have
all right thanks a lot
for the very nice talk yeah let's see if
there are questions yeah
[Music]
hello
thank you very much for the talk um i
would like to ask a question if you have
some intuition why in the stochastic
case you get the
if you go
two slides uh before that one uh
yep yeah that that one do we have um i
will focus in the l ellipses in
m strongly monotone case that is like
the bread and butter in the literature
why we get the one over epsilon squared
in comparison with one over epsilon
is it a very clear reason that we have
to get to one extra one over epsilon in
the stochastic case thank you very much
for the
yeah so
thank you it's a that's an excellent uh
question and fortunately not too hard to
explain uh so
are you familiar that in the setting
with min max
actually even in conducts optimization
if you have smooth strongly convex
function
for the optimality gap the complexity is
one over epsilon
can we agree on that yeah
okay
so the optimality gap is bounded by a
norm of the gradient squared
so to
translate from one over epsilon for one
over epsilon squared that's exactly
where the complexity comes from
uh you would need this so it's just a
direct uh reduction
because uh you would need to make the uh
gradient of the order one over
square root epsilon
if
you have
okay okay okay thank you thank you very
much yeah and then to get to this one
it's actually just based on our
algorithms so uh
we go from here to here using restarts
so what we argue is uh if you had
anything better than this you would
improve this bound and and then uh you
contradict the lower bound for electric
monotone
yeah
yeah thank you that's an excellent
question okay so there's another
question
oh hi helena this is is thank you for
the very nice thought i just have a few
questions on
so if we are considering l1 norm do you
think the definition of the gradient
being small still makes sense because
for example if you're thinking of a
constrained bilinear game where the
domain setup is l1
then i worry that
if we have a strong
duality gap guaranteed that would not
necessarily mean that the gradient in
any norm would necessarily be small so
this is my question
ah
i'm i'm
not sure i fully
followed the question soon and this is
just uh basically my misunderstanding uh
so for the l1 setting we would want to
bound the gradient in the l infinity
norm
so we always use the dual norm for for
for the gradients
um
like the gradient norm being small would
be a
uh would be a stronger uh like
it would imply that the stronger gap or
the weak duality gap my question is do
you think there are possibilities that
the there are solutions that satisfy
strong or weak duality gap but there is
no uh point that has small gradient
uh
okay
i
do not so so the general uh
correspondence between the problem
classes i talked about it calls for any
norms so if you can get a guarantee for
the optimality gap
for any
of these notions of gaps it would be
implied by the small
norm of of the gradient or of the
operator and
in terms of the existence of optimal
solutions if one exists all of them
exist
so so this is kind of
the notion of norm is irrelevant here
because of the
um equivalence of
norms in finite dimensions
the reason why we don't directly
translate from one norm to another
is that uh you would lose factors
polynomial in d
is that is that nice yeah yeah that
makes sense i i guess another way to say
a easy way to say my question is that if
we consider a constraint domain in
euclidean space
where
there is no solution so it's away from
the zero point so there's possibly no
solution that the gradient can be
possibly small if you oh oh i see see in
the constrained domains you wouldn't uh
want to make the gradient small you need
a different notion of stationarity i
just used the small gradient because it
was simple to describe because of the
um
it's a simple to describe notion of
stationarity if you go to constrained
domains uh you need
a different
definition of stationarity you need this
kind of local improvement
because you you need to account for for
the possibility of the solution uh
ending up at the boundary of the region
so all the results also extend to the
constraint case you're saying
uh the results from my 2020 paper extend
to constraint setups where you have
projections
okay okay some of the follow-up results
do not extend to
uh constrained setups yet
but i i think should be possible to
extend
okay okay cool yeah yeah thank you and
another question i have is would you
mind going back to the contribution of
your first paper page the comparison
between the rate and the state of the
art i was wondering yeah i'm probably
missing something so
i'm happy to add more north i have a
very basic question if there are l over
m rates in the literature for ellipsis
and m strongly monotone
why wouldn't that correspond to l over
epsilon rate in the ellipsis and
monotone case
oh that's a that's a very good
question
um
so
this
results uh here
was
proved for the extra gradient yeah and
it would make sense that it translates
into a lower epsilon
so
you can you if you use uh just uh
some type of regularization i guess you
can also get this result by uh losing
log one over epsilon but you would need
to know a bunch of parameters like uh
you would need an estimate of a distance
to opt
so you're saying the point of the
algorithm methods you list here is
because they are parameter free
yeah
yeah so you don't need any estimate of
distance to opt or or uh l or anything
else yeah that's actually a very good
point yeah i think
okay cool yeah thank you thank you
i do want people to have their break
so i have a couple questions i will just
ask you offline after this is over yeah
thank you very much
thank you sounds great thank you all
see you all